Black Panthers first cut came in at
around two and a half hours which means
there are some intriguing scenes and
concepts cut from the final movie we
never got to see you became if you
lovers it's Jan here and today I'm going
to reveal details about a deleted Rocky
style montage footage chopped from the
end of the movie two characters Ryan
Coogler wanted to include in the film
but couldn't and much more if you're
here for the first time I do regular
Marvel and deleted scenes videos plus
I've got a black panther giveaway
running right now for all my subscribers
so make sure you hit the bell and leave
me a comment with your thoughts about
the deleted scenes for a chance to win
obviously spoilers ahead for Black
Panther so take care if you haven't seen
it yet Black Panthers crew did an
amazing job bringing the nation of
Wakanda to vivid life on screen and if
writer director Ryan Coogler had had his
way we would have seen even more of the
incredible African nation in the final
film yes early drafts of the script
included a scene where two Chara and
Nakia went for a run through a candor -
Nikki is home speaking to Digital Spy
Kubler described the scene as a rocky
style jog pretty fitting given the
directors second feature film was Creed
although black panther had a very
healthy budget more in fact than several
of Marvel's other recent films in the
end the scene was cut to save money
though Kugler added that even if they
had shot it he doubts there have been
time for it in the final version I guess
because it wasn't essential to the
actual plot if the scene had made it
into the movie though not only would we
have been able to explore more of the
country but it would also have met Nikki
as parents and seen what they thought of
T'Challa their daughter's ex-boyfriend
chadwick boseman revealed are a couple
of deleted scenes of T'Challa and
Everett Ross in his office the scenes
he's referring to are likely after Ross
wakes up and talks to Cherie and
discovers that the bullet injury to his
spine has been healed with wakandan
technology it's the first time Ross has
ever seen Wakanda and Cherie tells him
not to touch anything
as her brother will soon return I think
there's a snippet of this deleted scene
in the second Black Panther trailer in
the form of a voiceover by Martin
Freeman which could match the discussion
he had with Charla in the scene that
I have seen God's fly I've seen men
build weapons that I couldn't even
imagine I've seen aliens drop from the
sky but I have never seen anything like
this and there's also some footage of
Everett Ross meeting with a Charlotte
and the wakandan delegation of the UN
which we never saw in the finished film
judging by Ross's body language in this
deleted clip here
I wonder if he might be trying to
dissuade to Charla from revealing the
truth about what candor were at least be
voicing his own doubts about what the
repercussions might be either way the
reason this footage is missing from the
theatrical release is that according to
Ryan Coogler the ending to the movie was
originally quite different initially to
Charla's UN speech about opening up more
candor to the rest of the world was
going to be the final scene before the
credits started to roll in an interview
with the Radio Times Kubler said it was
a complicated thing it was one of those
things where we were working on the
ending in the edits and we were kind of
deciding how we'd play it we knew we had
the ability to do a post-credits
sequence if we wanted to
koogler also explained that in the end
he wanted the final scene to parallel
the first scene in Oakland as he said if
you think about it the UN scene and the
scene that happens in Oakland are
basically the same scene
it's a reveal of who work and ins are
the only difference is who they're
revealing that to and we thought that it
was stronger emotionally to end in
Oakland
now what Kugler says does make absolute
sense though some Marvel fans might have
preferred if the UN speech have been in
the movie as we might have got an extra
end credits scene that way by the way if
you want to understand why the ending of
Black Panther is so important for the
MCU Plus how it sets up Avengers
infinity war then tap up here to watch
my full breakdown in the ending or click
the links in the video description below
the king's all-female bodyguard the door
Milosh I play a big part in some of the
movie's most spectacular action
sequences with Danai gurira giving an
awesome performance as Okoye yay but it
looks like there was still some
to the door as screen time last year
Vanity Fair reported that in an early
rough cut of footage from the film there
was a scene of the Dora Malaysia dancing
on a boat which featured to die career
as a coin yay and Florence kizomba zyau
swaying rhythmically back in formation
with the rest of their team a koi yay
eyes io flirtatiously for a long time as
a camera pans in on them eventually she
says appreciatively and appraisingly you
look good io responds in kind and Akoya
grins and replies I know while some of
the dancing did make it into the final
film the flirtation between a quarry and
IO who in the comics has a romantic
relationship with another Dora milosh a
was Kurt in an interview with vulture IO
actress kizomba seemed to confirm the
moment had been filmed but thus it was
given the chop while kizomba couldn't
confirm the reason for its removal she
suggested it might have been because the
movie had a lot to do in introducing the
world work anda and needed to keep the
focus on T'Challa
however this isn't the first time this
has seen which hints towards an LGBTQ
character has been cut from a Marvel
movie the most recent being in Thor
Ragnarok where a scene of a woman
leaving Valkyries bedroom was deleted
from the film in the MCU s Black Panther
ikuyo is in a relationship with Maccabi
and that ends up being significant in
the movies finale so I wonder whether
that played any part in the decision to
drop the earlier moment between a coy
way and IO and interview with the film's
co-writer Joe Robert Cole indicates that
may be the case as he suggests that they
did have the LGBTQ storyline from the
comics in mind though it wouldn't have
been a major theme and they also
discussed many different arcs for
different characters and although
kizomba has said that she felt it was
important in this first film to clearly
establish the door menagerie as a unit
she would still like IO sexuality to be
explored in a future Black Panther movie
Michael B Jordans kill manga has been
rightfully praised for bringing an
excellent antagonist into the MCU
however in the early stages ryan coogler
who's a comics fan himself had plans to
introduce a different villain into the
movie that villain was Kraven the hunter
who first appeared in the amazing
spider-man comics and is a big-game
hunter koogler particularly enjoyed
Christopher priests run on the Black
Panther comics were panther fort craven
however Marvel told him he couldn't use
the character I suspect because Kraven
was introduced in the spider-man comics
the character is bundled up with Sony's
spider-man rights obviously we do have
spider-man in the MCU right now however
that was a specific arrangement which
Marvel Studios had to broker with sony
Sony themselves are developing their own
spider-man related universe which
appears to be separate to the MCU with
characters like venom silver sable and
black cat and possibly even Craven
himself with ryan coogler and Joe Robert
Cole started working on ideas for the
movie another character they seriously
considered about including was Patriot
aka Elijah Bradley who's one of the
founders of the Young Avengers in the
comics Patriot is the grandson of Isaiah
Bradley who was one of the 300
african-american soldiers used as test
subjects for the Super Soldier Serum the
thing is though Patriots isn't actually
part of Black Panther story in the
comics and that's why Kugler ultimately
decided against introducing him in the
movie as he wanted to concentrate more
and more candor and characters who are
already part of that world
showing us the nation of Wakanda in all
its glorious detail was always going to
be a central part of the black panther
film but so was traveling beyond the
African country's borders as the
filmmakers wanted to give a sense of
some of the effects of wakanda's
isolationism
but while the finished film
globe-trotting Busan South Korea Oakland
California London Vienna and Nigeria
sambisa forest an early draft of the
movie also included a sequence in
Chicago
according to screenwriter Joe Robert
Cole it was going to be a pretty big
scene though sadly he didn't elaborate
one of the standouts in Black Panther
was Leticia Wright Cherie tech genius
into Charlie's little sister
Cherie is also an interesting character
in the comics who's taken on the mantle
of Black Panther herself on occasions
and in fact that issue writers said she
thought Ryan Coogler had toyed with the
idea of setting up
shuri is a black panther and i can see a
little hint to that in the neck piece
with Panther teeth that she wore in some
scenes of the movie for the moment
though I expect a Charlie will be the
only Black Panther ensure his appearance
as an Avengers infinity war and other
crossovers will again showcase her
incredible tech skills and ability to
create highly advanced gadgets but
perhaps when Black Panther sequel
arrives in phase four we could see Shuri
put on a black panther suit she could
either be an additional black panther to
T'Challa or she could take over from him
for example if he were injured after all
there were three suits in her lab
T'Challa took one of course and I think
kill monger took the gold tooth necklace
which would conveniently leave one spur
for her and that's without even counting
any future suits she might design now
what do you think of any of the deleted
scenes or things that didn't make it
into black panther is there anything you
wish have been included or are you happy
with the final version let me know your
thoughts in the comments below and don't
forget to also subscribe to enter my
black panther giveaway if you enjoyed
this do hit the like button and share
the video and why not join the
notification squad by clicking the bell
for all my new videos also tap any of
the links here to check out more videos
you might like thanks for watching and
see you next time you became movie
lovers